I completely forgot that I'm at
Disneyland once that was amazing oh
great yeah that was a good trip well
then it started to get bad when people
started to ask me pictures of kids
welcome everybody to another episode of
hot box and with Mike Tyson I'm Evan
Brittain
Mike Tyson there he is yeah obviously
how are you I think we got a great guest
yeah I think I might have offended her
earlier by saying I grew up watching her
show well when you said that I imagined
like a little kid growing up so I do use
a giant thank you
fantasy factory with rob dyrdek yes yeah
it has been a long time it's crazy
really crazy I didn't think I need a
record deal yes I did music my whole
life and I kind of got discovered by Rob
through MySpace I was trying to get
discovered by record label somehow got
discovered by Rob so then that's how I
ended up on the shows and I just you
know I stayed on the shows and what I've
always wanted to do those music so I
stayed doing my thing pursuing my music
and through some connections I met
little Wayne and he really liked my
music and I was supposed to be with
Young Money which is that's a whole
other long story but yeah so no time
there is yes well basically you know I
was with Wayne he co-signed me and then
some things with him and Birdman
happened like right after that and then
that put a lot of things on hold with
the Young Money record labels so that
put things on hold with me essentially
but I stayed doing my thing and I've
been putting out you know
song after song Cindy yes where can
people check your music out after
anywhere music is available everywhere
all the streaming platforms yes title
Amazon wherever you like to listen to
music you could find it okay Chanel
who's gonna be your first rap beef
that's a funny question I don't know
maybe Mike I was like okay Mike likes
the devil fist
no pun intended
Mike yes you were just on ridiculousness
yes what's ridiculousness all about now
yeah you're Episode II that's just what
Rob Dyrdek does I don't think Rob
doesn't even smoke Rob sober clean as a
whistle
but I don't I don't smoke before I go on
ridiculousness though get too small and
then I I think I don't look as pretty
you know what I mean so trying to look
my best so I don't know DMT no no that
type of stuff I can't do I know
mushrooms mushrooms i but like I can't
like I'm a small person and so like
anything other than weed makes me just
trip out too hard Bri fro from the
valley yeah what part I I went to high
school and middle school in Burbank okay
I went in on the other side of the
valley I went to Portola in Taft okay
cool good football team yeah I went to I
went to school was like a lot of people
probably a bunch of guys that played in
the league right now are you Texans fan
well I am now my family is a really big
Texans fan so uh yeah my cousin Ashley's
husband was like I don't know fifth
generation like Clem
and deshaun Watson used to play for
Clemson they went on to become Texan
fans because of him and they saw that he
was on ridiculousness
and so ever since that episode I've been
asked about him non-stop and being
introduced and my little cousins I just
like kind of wanted to make their dream
come true which I did so yeah so I
brought them to the game look at you
yeah people like Mike Tyson you know
deshaun Watson and getting to you know
connect my family with like their fans
and stuff I've got to do that a lot
through that show so that's awesome
yeah Zach how are you doing great man
little stone add some paperwork in the
office earlier so I had taken the
podcast yeah do a little hotbox and
chill out have a conversation Chanel
what's your take on cannabis might take
on cannabis overall yeah I definitely
think that some people really need it
it's definitely medicine you know
growing up I was the kid that it was
always in trouble for talking too much
being disruptive in class and I believe
I had a DD no I mean I'm a naturally
like really hyperactive person and I
feel that it levels me out you know what
I mean and once this weed came into my
life I'm not gonna lie I think it made
me have more friends because I might
talk too much without it so I might have
been annoying if I never started smoking
but yeah I think it's like people like
me need it like I get anxiety and like I
smoke and I'm like the chillest person
ever you know so um and and it helps me
sleep because like I said I'm so hyper
like if I didn't smoke like I go to go
to bed really late and I'll still wake
up really early and like I need my sleep
obviously so it helps with that and I
think that you know there's a lot of
people like me who like it's meant for
you know what I'm saying yeah no duh
yeah that's us when were you first
introduced to it
when I was like when I was like 11 or 12
Wow okay I mean I'm from LA you know
like this is a weed state so people
smoke here too young age
you know I always was like a STONER but
I never got into drinking and I remember
in high school everybody was like
sneaking alcohol and drinking and
getting drunk it was always the people
that were drinking that did the really
stupid [ __ ] got into car accidents got
DUIs underage right got pregnant at a
young age like I was the one who I fell
asleep at 10:00 because I was high you
know I remember I missed like two new
years in a row because I was so high so
it's like it kept me out of trouble you
know what I mean it's like it's a chill
thing you know I don't I think these
they have those funny commercials where
it's like people do these like stupid
ass things and that's not how it is your
brain on drugs
your I think you I think yeah whenever
you're high you actually think of things
slower paced you know whatever you're
drunk you're just like do whatever
because everything's okay when you're
drunk you know what I mean
yeah like what do you think no
psychedelics oh yeah Mike's been really
really into the toad I think he this
guy's gonna be taking trips down to the
Amazon pretty soon what do you think
dude possibility but I got my own shop
innovating I know you did you do and you
got one of the best in the world dr.
Jerry the man he's well you watch you so
you're starting to educate yourself yeah
you're in now bro isn't that crazy that
he didn't watch any of the documentaries
before he's like okay really you would
have said [ __ ] that
really why no the guys are freaking out
oh who were taking it but since you had
that first time yeah that was awesome
where were you really freaked out right
in the beginning has in the times you've
done it after have you been freaking
good are you talking about the ayahuasca
thing this well yes we're talking about
the toad medicine okay what's that
and that toad is we had this guy dr.
Jerry come in and the toad is five Meo
DMT so it's the same active ingredient
that's in ayahuasca but it's like a step
above so they call DMT the spirit
molecule they call five Meo DMT the god
Moloch
because it takes you right to the source
okay and it helps people dealing with
addiction it cures depression and
anxiety and all of this stuff because it
really shows you a lot of your trauma
you know and it helps you put your life
into context and you get a great
understanding of you know we are all one
we are all together connected you know
it releases all of your trauma and
you're able to let go right Mike
absolutely and so if you go through an
ego death is what they all say so you
have an ego death and that's really what
is so scary for people because you it
dissolves any idea that you have of who
you are supposed to be or who you think
you're supposed to be and it shows you
your true self and that's really a
beautiful thing
don't you think Mike but it can be
really scary and that's why yeah I
wonder if I could handle it honestly
because like all those trip out like
even I did shrooms the first time by
accident it was on some pizza at a party
I just ate the pizza because I had the
munchies and had shrooms on it oh yeah
was but at first it was really fun and
then it started to be like a bad trip
and it was like I'm like I don't I don't
want to do [ __ ] like that you know like
I get I don't know at what point did you
realize oh [ __ ] I must have ate
mushrooms well this is how because some
guy in the kitchen was like well he was
like oh he's like you took the shroom
pizza and I was like what do you mean
like I was like yes it was scary yeah
and so he's kind of like pointed it out
and he thought I was like eating it on
purpose and I was just eating pizza to
eat pizza yeah I did that one time a try
to partying milligrams of edibles 50
milligrams
I asked guys like this guy to THC he's
like no and I thought oh my god I'm
going around Patti this party passed
yeah these cookies are so good oh just
CBD and I went to that guy and he's like
I went to give him one and he's like how
many edibles are so good he's like 50
grams I was like 50 I was like 50 grams
per one I suggest meat 500 I was
freaking out dude the worst that trip
I've had way too much is the worst
feeling in the world
Oh got me a lot
mushrooms are cool too mushrooms are
really great I think that it's all about
setting setting though oh yeah actually
I completely forgot did him at
Disneyland once that was amazing oh
great yeah that was a good trip well
then it started to get bad when people
started to ask me for pictures I was
like oh [ __ ] and then somebody came up
he was like a bunch of kids like yeah it
was fun until then I definitely could
not do shrooms before Disneyland no you
could trust me it made like all the kid
rides become the fight like they have
like all these like really slow just you
know colorful rides like it's like the
Pinocchio one sober we'd be like oh my
gosh I can't believe I've to sit through
this yeah in my head I'm picturing in
you you in there that ride with a bunch
of little kids any big what's this adult
doing with us what's it like to be an
anomaly do you get a lot of [ __ ] do you
well I mean it's really hard obviously I
feel like you know there's a lot more
men numbers than female first of all and
I think just as a female forget being
white that's a whole nother thing but as
a female I think that we don't stick
together enough like the guys they all
like they're all homies they all collab
with each other they're like well you
know it's like all the guys act like a
family and the girls are
more like competitive about it right so
with the girls it's like they don't come
they don't come together as much so I
feel like that's why we're not as strong
of a unit and I keep trying to preach
like hey come together girls and then
maybe we'll be able to make more of an
impact yeah girls are just very insecure
and they don't know how to like you know
put their guard down and team up with
other girls and know that it's not a
competition you know what I mean yeah so
I think that as a girls it's harder
because you know it's a I think we
compete with each other a lot more than
the guys do you know then that makes a
lot of sense yeah
what about throw a mic on a track that
would be shine now West Coast watching
on the TV you have rapping when they
coming out of a club oh well this will
happen so my girlfriend was next to me
and I guess a drunk I tried to like grab
her but and and my homie was dating her
and so when the guy tried to grab her
but he got mad and was like yo like back
up and I don't know what's going down
behind me claps oh [ __ ] and this dude
just hit my boy behind me and I didn't
see it until I saw it on camera I felt
so bad for him after I heard about it
was
no cuz literally we were and then we
like separated right after that and so
then the next day everybody's like dude
did you see what happened I was like get
behind me I didn't even know you were
you just like rapping on your way into a
car no I was leaving the club and like
TMZ saw me and they were like of course
you know well where can people check you
out now what are you up to
what's your latest thing well I got a
lot of new music dropping in the new
year so I want to get people excited for
what I got coming it's gonna be a new
song I got coming out called Sheeran
stoned yes it's gonna be really dope so
that's gonna be dropping in February
awesome yes as for all my stoners
obviously with a song title like Sharon
Stone
so iTunes everywhere yeah it's gonna
it's gonna be everywhere so that's
that's my next single coming out and
then my albums gonna come out right
after that obviously another season or
yeah I have on Instagram I have like
three something million and then on
Facebook I have like five million
something yeah they got reach yeah we're
trying to get more but you know what are
you I don't think I posted enough
aspects I don't know nothing it's crazy
I feel like that's I feel like that's
what it's kind of become so it is it's
terrible I'm like instagrams become like
porno gram but well keep doing your
thing thank you chanel west coast on
Instagram yes chanel west coast
everywhere Instagram Facebook Twitter
anything
I am chanel west coast calm because
somebody stole chanel west coast and
they're like in like some little random
country like outside of Russia what do
you need chanel west coast
yeah what are you and they're doing
nothing with it nothing I don't know who
knows sons of [ __ ] yeah well it was
really awesome having you today thank
you thank you for having me I appreciate
you thank you for coming Zach thing
for hey guys I always fun to be in
there's you guys you're the man come at
any time you to Chanel
thank you I will smell is amazing right
when you walk in yeah yes it's a place
I'd like to I'd like to hang out for
sure well come anytime
I'm sure we'll get you hooked up with
some good cannabis products I would love
it thank you
and until next time everybody Mike great
job man
hey Anne thing's awesome all right I'm
Evan Britain I'm Mike Tyson we're out of
here
yes I'm here